Speaker 1: This is a major story we're starting
with here.
Republicans have been caught in a series of
presentations, audio recordings and PowerPoints
openly planning to win elections, not by actually
winning the hearts and minds of voters and
getting people to the polls and winning elections
in a real way.
They've been caught planning to win by a strategic
and concerted effort to just contests ballots
to claim fraud.
And this plan, in and of itself is a form
of voter fraud.
We are going to listen to the recordings.
We are going to look at what we have learned.
And one of the things that I said back in
2020, when six months before the November
2020 election, Donald Trump and others started
saying, oh, it's going to be fraud.
He would say fraud.
He would say the paper ballots, the mail in
ballots, absentee, it's all fraudulent.
They're going to try to take it.
It's going to be insecure.
And what I said at the time was, you know,
at some point in the future, they are actually
going to attempt massive voter fraud and we're
going to call them out.
And then they're going to say, oh, come on,
you're the guys who said there was no fraud
when we were pointing to the fraud in 2020.
And that is happening right now because remember,
with Republicans, with the modern right wing
in the United States, every time they make
an allegation, we should consider and explore
whether it's actually a confession of something
they're planning to do.
Oh, Hillary can't be trusted with with sensitive
information.
Trump's eating documents, flashing documents
and stealing documents to Mar a Lago.
When they say the left is doing something,
the first question we should ask is, are they
actually the ones doing this?
Is that how they think?
It's something someone might do because they
are the ones doing it.
So they are conspiring to win elections, win
by contesting ballots of Democrats, not by
actually convincing people to vote for them.
Explosive political report.
It's going to be in.
Army tapes revealed Republican plan to contest
elections, placing operatives as poll workers
and building a hotline to friendly attorneys
are among the strategies to be deployed in
Michigan and other swing states.
This is incredibly important stuff to know
about now because if we're not ready to fight
this, they could get away with it.
Think about, you know, thank goodness they
didn't get away with it in 2020.
But you could argue that it was a trial run
and that they're going to try again and there's
every indication they're going to.
Heidi PRZYBYLA for Politico, quote, Video
recordings of Republican Party operatives
meeting with grassroots grassroots activists
provide an inside look at a multipronged strategy
to target and potentially overturn votes in
Democratic precincts.
They're targeting the Democratic precincts,
install trained recruits as regular poll workers,
and put them in direct contact with party
attorneys.
The plan is outlined by a Republican National
Committee staffer in Michigan includes utilizing
rules designed to provide political balance
among poll workers to install party trained
volunteers prepared to challenge voters as
Democratic majority polling places at Democratic
majority polling places.
Developing a website to connect workers to
local lawyers and establishing a network of
party friendly deejays who could intervene
to block vote counts at certain precincts.
So here is the strategy.
Okay.
Most polling places, generally speaking, have
a system for poll workers and poll watchers.
Most of those systems are designed that there
be partizan balance.
You can't have all Democrats watching a poll,
a polling place or all Republicans.
The idea would be you have a partizan balance,
but these are all just kind of good faith,
people who are there genuinely to make sure
that everything is being done in the correct
way.
The Republican plan is to take advantage of
the rules which say you have to have some
Democrats and some Republicans.
There has to be balance.
And to train the Republican poll workers to
understand how to disproportionately challenge
Democratic votes by virtue of being an overwhelmingly
Democratic precincts in order to have balance
on paper.
Listen, we've still got Democratic poll workers
and Republican poll workers.
It's all fine.
But the Republican workers that are the poll
workers that are there are they're not to
make sure everything is on the up and up,
but they are there because these are left
leaning precincts where they are going to
try to help Republicans by challenging votes.
That will statistically be more likely to
be Democratic rather than Republican votes.
Being a poll worker, you just have so many
more rights and things you can do to stop
something than as a poll challenger.
So again, the idea here is don't have them
there as the obviously partizan poll challengers
have them there just as regular poll workers
who are going to say they're seeing funny
business.
We have audio recordings.
Let's take a listen to one.
Speaker 2: Understand that we are upset with
the 2020 results, but we cannot just look
at the 2020 results because the exact same
thing will happen in 2022.
We need volunteers on the ground on Election
Day, ahead of Election Day working so that
that prior does not happen again.
If we only look at it one night, it just will
happen.
I worked the polls the last election, and
not only were we extremely poorly trained,
I mean badly trained, but when we caught them
cheating and I caught them cheating, they
they had a preplanned thing that they did.
They would swarm you.
They blocked you from seeing things.
They accused you of doing things that you
weren't doing.
And then they would go like this and have
the police come in as we're too loud.
So that that's why we're here now, today,
13 months ahead of Saturday as opposed as
opposed to one month ago.
So if I could ask everyone just to listen.
Speaker 1: And by the way, the reason that
they're saying 13 months is the recordings
from October.
These recordings were just recently published.
So they're talking about October 20, 21, 13
months before this coming November election.
This plan is for the November election.
Speaker 2: And you go through the presentation,
you think you appear to have you can ask questions
after.
Speaker 3: But seriously, seriously, that's
why we're on the ground, like Rob said, so
early to address exactly that.
Right.
The Democrats are going to go off stage now
right away.
So we are trying to recruit and truly it's
going to be an arm, right?
We are going to try to recruit lawyers.
We're going to have more lawyers than they
have ever been recruited, because that's not
that's where it's going to be fought.
Right.
We're going to have lawyers that work early
to build relationships with different judges
so that when that happens, we're going to
have lawyers that have relationships with
the police chiefs in the different areas.
Speaker 1: The police chief, the police.
So you're going to have install Republican
bad faith poll workers to contest ballots,
have them be in touch with lawyers.
And the lawyers know the police chiefs.
So maybe they can even involve police in helping
to skew the elections in their favor in.
Speaker 3: The different areas.
So when that happens, is preexisting relationships
already established so that they can't lie?
Or so I think I've talked to so many people
that were at the TCF Center and that that
I have heard I haven't seen it happen.
Right.
No one has described it happen and it's wrong.
And it's 100% all that it happened.
And we're going to address it.
We're going to address it by having a lawyers
on the ground.
When I address it, I find it.
Speaker 1: So the plan is as follows In most
places, in many places, we'll talk about Detroit,
Michigan, because this is one one place that
this is becoming a very big deal.
The poll workers have to be selected from
name submitted by each of the parties.
Right.
So we know that Detroit is a particularly
blue part of Michigan.
So if you want to skew a state election, you
don't know whether a particular voter is a
Republican or a Democrat.
So you say, okay, well, listen, if Michigan,
as in general, is a I don't I don't know what
the numbers are.
Imagine it's a 52 to 48 state or a 5545 Democratic
leaning state.
But, you know, Detroit is like 75% Democratic.
Great.
So what you do is you train a bunch of people
to be poll workers who know the process for
contesting ballots, say, I don't believe that
this is a valid voter.
You force them to have to submit a contested
ballot, which then has to be adjudicated,
and on and on and on.
You train them up.
And then the list that the Republican Party
submits in Detroit.
Right.
They don't have to do this.
Everywhere you say we're going to target Detroit
because that's where we can make a difference.
It's so many Democrats will try to fight the
validity of Democratic ballots for no particular
reason other than they're Democrats.
The lists that you submit in Detroit to the
county, to the election clerk or the Detroit
official that chooses the poll workers, is
all these people who have been trained in
bad faith not to prevent fraud, but to try
to get votes in Detroit thrown out, which
are overwhelmingly likely to be Democratic
votes.
And so then that's how you skew the results.
You let the vote happen in other parts of
Michigan that are more 5050 or even the rural
parts of Michigan, which skew Republican.
But in Detroit, you send this army of poll
workers who are actually bad faith, sort of
like undercover political operatives to try
to get Democratic votes discounted.
And they've got lawyers ready.
They claim they're going to have police chiefs
ready.
Now, what is happening here is that to win,
they increasingly must cheat, at least apparently.
Well, why would that?
It's because on the issues, the country is
moving more and more to the left that they
are losing on the issues.
Okay.
And by the way, I encourage you to listen
to these recordings in full.
There's an eight minute recording from an
October 5th election integrity training, and
then there's another 14 minute recording of
a Zoom meeting.
And you will very quickly understand the strategy,
which we have more or less explained here.
If Democrats wait until after it happens,
it's going to be too late.
And it's really important to understand how
monumental the outcome of these midterms will
be, because in 2020, they had a bunch of different
strategies.
They tried it was the national they can pence
overturn it alternate slates of electors objections
on January 6th all these different things.
More than 60 court cases which failed trying
to prevent mail in and absentee ballots.
They had all these different things.
It didn't work, but it could have.
And now they're going to refine the strategy.
And 2022 is going to be a test of how much
closer can we get to just controlling the
election results by using these techniques
so that in 2024, we might be able to just
get a president that didn't really win installed
in the White House.
And there's a second layer to that.
It's not just testing the techniques.
It's also can we use the techniques in 2022,
we being them can we use the techniques in
2022 to get enough control over state positions,
including secretaries of state and governors,
etc., so that those individuals will be in
power in November of 2024 to maybe do what
Trump wanted.
Brad Raffensperger and Brian Kemp to do in
Georgia, for example.
Remember that I.
Speaker 4: Need 11,000 votes.
Give me a break.
Speaker 1: It didn't happen in Georgia.
But what about Doug Mastriano in Pennsylvania?
Doug Mastriano, the now winner of the Republican
gubernatorial primary in Pennsylvania.
He's a big lie supporter and he's worse than
that.
By the way, if you look at his background,
he might be willing to do the things Trump
wanted them to do in Georgia in 2024 if he's
the governor.
So what if they use these techniques to get
mastriano in in 2022 so that he will be in
power to do this stuff in 2024?
We cannot understate the importance of these
midterms.
So should everyone vote?
Of course, that's number one.
But the Democratic Party had better be ready
to fight this.
Now, do they have to fight fire with fire?
Meaning just set up Democratic poll workers
to try to do this exact same thing in Republican
areas?
Well, number one, I think that that's going
low.
So I don't think that's the way to do it.
And number two, by its nature, because Republicans
are more predominant in rural areas with lower
populations, Democrats are at a structural
disadvantage.
Republicans can focus their bad faith poll
workers in the densely populated areas.
For Democrats to fight that, they would need
way more poll workers because you would need
them in way more precincts because they're
going to be more rural precincts.
So it's both a bad idea and a difficult idea
logistically because of that.
So Democrats need to come up with something
and I don't know what the answer is.
I just learned about this story yesterday.
I'm still thinking about it, but it is looking
very, very rough.
Let me know what you think.
Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
And Tuesday, June 14th, at 6 p.m. will be
the next David Pakman show town hall.
It'll stream live on the Pacman Live YouTube
channel.
I'll have more information on that between
now and then